you can add the protein by giving the
gene for it you can make organisms that
they and their progeny and their
subsequent project will make this as a
normal part of their growth and one can
see the fluorescence in the living cells
and in the living organisms you can
either you can label the cells you can
label whole organisms you can as my wife
Tula hazel Rick showed you can put GFP
the gene for GFE next to the gene
encoding a protein that you're
interested in and now you make a fusion
protein first part or one part of the
protein is the protein you're interested
in the other part is this Lantern GFP
that you can attach to it so wherever
that protein goes that's where the GFP
goes and so you can see wherever the
protein goes and in living organisms the
other thing about it is that that's all
you need to look at it is to shine blue
or ultraviolet now we just use blue
light and you see it's wherever it
happens to be because it's green against
the background in which there is no Brie
and so you can see things once you can
see so that allows you to